o
já passaram algumas coisas que eu ia
mostrar
de pouquinho em pouquinho eu vou
apresentar a vocês o kraft terra
enquanto uma possibilidade inovadora mas
antes disso é o chico já nos ensinou que
tem que contextualizar primeiro né então
vou contextualizar márcio hann filho de
hélio e antonieta com o irmão de hélio
recado e yami arquiteto formado aqui
nesta instituição professor marido um
casado com minha companheira e amor
lúcia pai de lucas tiago eletícia muito
curioso viciado em conhecimento e
viciado em ajudar o próximo
não é à toa que eu sou servidor público
federal aqui desta instituição
então lembrei muito curioso viciado em
conhecimento e viciado em ajudar o
próximo
e aí vamos entrar num possibilidades
inovadoras e vem a pergunta o que fazer
com as embalagens do saco de cimento e
são muitas
hoje no nosso país só no brasil a gente
tá chegando já a casa de 1 bilhão de
unidades de sacos de cimento despachados
ao comércio todo ano eu vou com somar a
isso aí outros sacos que usam outras
embalagens que usam o papel kraft eu vou
ter o quê h massas sementes e adubos e
outros tantos a quantidade é enorme
então o que fazer com as embalagens dos
sacos de cimento
mas na verdade não foi com essa enchente
investigação com essa pergunta que veio
a idéia do kraft terra
o kraft terra na verdade a ideia surgiu
de uma constatação na verdade surgiu de
uma grande bagunça no canteiro de obras
nós estamos
zb tcc's que são blocos de terra
compactados feitos com o solo natural
aquecimento
tá então a produção zinha resumindo
basicamente o que pegava solo natural
pegava o saco de cimento abriga jogava
ministrada na proporção os a embalagem e
atolado e aí mais um pouquinho fazia na
embalagem outro lado caiu um pouquinho
de terra em cima chovia um pouquinho e
outro saco mais uma chuva mais uma
terrinha aquela colega é uma bagunça no
canteiro de obras
chegou uma hora que a gente falou não
vamos arrumar e aí quando começaram a
fazer a limpeza aquele cantinho do saco
estava muito duro extremamente rígido
uma dificuldade tremenda e aí a valesca
nem falou pra gente assim a pesquisa
normalmente começa como uma estranheza
estranhei o ordinário estranhei o
simples porém eu não me preocupei só em
limpar aquilo me interessou porque que
aquilo estava tão duro e aí veio será
que eu consigo fazer alguma coisa com
essas embalagens que horas são resíduos
e entulhos de obras aí eu consigo pegar
essas embalagens e fazer algo para
reforçar ou para melhorar o desempenho
de componentes elementos constitutivos e
usar na própria cadeia produtiva da
indústria da construção civil e aí veio
a idéia do kraft terra está o que fazer
na verdade a frente nós temos que ter
quanto mais enxergar possibilidades
quanto mais melhor
usualmente a gente tem o que o mais
fácil descartar
jogar fora é o que na grande maioria das
vezes é feito mas eu posso fazer telha
possa fazer caderninhos posso voltar a
fazer papel posso fazer artesanato
sacolas posso fazer o revestimento de
piso revestimento de paredes
tem um monte de gente pensando só que a
quantidade de entulho é tão grande
tá e aí eu percebi que na verdade eles
pensavam sempre em voltar a coisa a usar
o próprio papel e eu pensei na
possibilidade de usar
a fibra do papel mudou um pouquinho a
característica dela e incorporar isso ao
que eu já estava acostumado a trabalhar
que é a arquitetura de terra
então como ver se os dois funcionam
antes eu tive que primeiro e voltei pra
trás
agora eu tenho que primeiro fazer o
seguinte não me limitar por preconceitos
e saber os impostos seja por tradições
mitos ou mesmo pelo senso comum
ouvia muito dizer que não reciclar o
saco de cimento papel kraft não compensa
economicamente
então não vamos aceitar a pasta do kraft
é muito barata então se incorporar esse
esse saco aí que em alguns países é um
resíduo tóxico e perigoso
então vai dar trabalho eu sempre ouvi
falar sobre isso ainda mas vamos dar um
jeito
e outra coisa que eu sempre ouvi falar é
de arquitetura de terra que não é uma
boa não é uma construção boa fase só a
enquete bem rápida quem hoje numa boa
moraria na casa de terra 123 um
pouquinho só pois é nós aprendemos desde
pequenininhos que morar em casas de
terra não é muito bom lá na história
geografia lá embaixo no nosso na nossa
literatura nossas fontes lá de de ensino
fundamental tem uma coisa que fala assim
taipa de mão ou pau a pique jovem fala
de pau-a-pique palpite tem trinca a
trinca tem barbeiro barbeiro da doença
de chagas doença de chagas de mata você
morreu
por dedução arquitetura de terra morreu
não vale a pena
tá então é mais ou menos que a gente
aprende desde pequenininho tá e é que a
arquitetura de terra é uma coisa pra que
as pessoas que não têm aonde morrer
perfeito não temos morrer arquitetura e
até por dedução morreu tal quando
resolve os dois e não é bem assim está a
gente tem arquitetura de terra
mundialmente pesquisada utilizar
em muitos países e nós conseguimos
construir com terra de uma forma
exemplar
esse aqui são exemplos pessoal taipal
trabalha muito bem com terra lá de de
campinas e temos inúmeros exemplos aqui
no país e no mundo inteiro construções
que são duráveis confortáveis e
eficientes está a terra é um regulador
hidrotérmico quando usado adequadamente
você regula temperatura e umidade de uma
maneira passiva sem precisar trabalhar
com calefação sem precisar ligar o ar
condicionado está e é o material barato
durável ecológico e assim por diante
por que não usar então eu tirei isso da
frente e falei também porque não
reciclar o saco de cimento e com essas
duas foi pra frente e aí uma das coisas
que me fez é que me ajudou a pesquisar a
trabalhar com kraft terra foi a maneira
como eu lidava com as coisas
lembro a seja curioso tá sou muito
curioso e eu sempre procurei explorar o
mundo compreender a natureza e continuar
sendo curioso tá esse nível de glaci
tyson ele eu vi uma palestra que lhe deu
ele falou o seguinte
aprenda como as coisas funcionam isso dá
poder de influenciar e eventos tirar o
poder para ajudar pessoas que talvez
precisem te dá autoridade
fiquei muito feliz hoje com a conta do
recado em que aquela turma de 250 ali
inicialmente podia até pensar aquelas
pessoas todas pensadas estavam pensando
que naquele ambiente de ensino
aprendizado ali só tinha um que tinha
autoridade que era o professor
eu sempre pergunto aos meus alunos no
primeiro dia de aula do que ela criou
aquele clima e falou quem é que tem
autoridade aqui nessa sala é que ela né
certamente que eles fala o senhor
professor unam e eu viro falas estão
errados na verdade todos aqui nós todos
temos o potencial de em algum momento
a autoridade autoridade nada mais é do
que o poder que alguém tem de fazer o
outro crescer
e aí vem aquela coisa de vício em ajudar
o próximo
tá então assim o professor parabéns
senhor criou várias autoridades
é isso aí é exemplo e isso foi básico
pra mim também tá comendo que hoje muito
do da falta de inovação da falta de
possibilidades inovadoras tá nessa tal
de crise da fé que que é isso
confesso para vocês encontram várias
pessoas que se sentem incapazes de
trocar até uma lâmpada queimada
não sei trocar uma lâmpada queimada como
é que isto não seu funcionamento não sei
perdeu o domínio nós grande parte das
pessoas perdemos o domínio do saber
fazer
até fazemos construir mesmo que a minha
área é muito fácil é muito fácil
levantar uma parede de alvenaria de
tijolo furado qualquer um pega uma
colher de pedreiro e levanta com muita
facilidade fazer
ele sabe saber o porquê que está fazendo
aquilo é bem diferente e nós perdemos
muito isso
então o saber fazer você vai dominar ou
você vai ser dominado e pra aprender o
como que mexer com esse tal de kraft até
eu pensei que precisava terminar lo a
aprender a saltar o saber fazer e aí
passou muito até chegar nessa receita
zinha eu tenho no final das contas
depois no final da pesquisa uma receita
e algumas dicas ao final cheguei a uma
conclusão que o solo natural terra com
6% de fibras provenientes da reciclagem
dos aquecimento e conceitos 6% só de
cimento eu consigo fazer um material
bastante resistente melhor como
desempenho melhor do que o usual tá e as
dicas de como trabalhar com isso
nessas dicas que foi interessante é e
tava tendo dificuldade em fazer a
mistura colocava primeiro há o solo
depois colocava as fibras depois vinha
com cimento e aí a água depois não botar
o cimento primeiro a ordem de colocação
estava me dando um problema enorme
eu criava algumas bolinhas onde se
concentravam as fibras e aí eu nunca
tinha um produto homogêneo que era
necessário para fazer um bom jogo longo
a parede e aí olhando a minha cozinheira
a haja jamie ela fazer uma bela mesa a
mesa e ela não botava aquela faria
aquela cobertura de uma vez era dos
pouquinho em pouquinho porque essa taxa
de uma vez ela ao fritar soltava e eu
falei cara será que é assim e aí
coloquei a fibra primeiro um pouquinho
de solo-cimento só ver aquelas
geraldinho aquela milanesa aquela
coisinha pequenininha e depois eu
botando restantes depois e funcionou
falei cara da onde eu fui pegar essa
ideia né
e aí a receita é simples demorou muito
para chegar nisso mas eu nunca desistir
eu sabia que era possível e o que me
ajudava que me ajudou a chegar aí foi só
aqui eu sabia que eu só iria fazer o que
era possível pra mim o que não fosse eu
não iria
mas eu podia mudar esse impossível ver
de uma forma diferente se reinventar e
se possível e também a certeza de que eu
tinha muita fé na força que deus me deu
na minha inteligência na minha
curiosidade na minha vontade de conhecer
o mundo conhecer a natureza de mudar
esse contribuir para mudar esse mundo e
contribuir na formação das pessoas
e aí que tá e del nisso hoje com kraft
terra eu consigo fazer tijolos blocos h
massas de assentamento h massa de
revestimentos ea casa inteira coberturas
piso teto paredes
o material extremamente barato os
arquitetura de terra que no nosso país
não é muito aceita ainda
mas há sim muito bom não só para vocês
terem um exemplo com a uma casa muito
pequena 50 metros quadrados dois quartos
uma sala uma pequena cozinha um pequeno
banheiro utah é eu consigo com tijolos
aparentes de se eu consigo incorporar a
esta casa o correspondência mais ou
menos 15 mil sacos de cimento que iriam
para a natureza
se eu a mandar um pouquinho a espessura
das paredes
eu consigo chegar a 20 e 25 mil numa
pequenina casa imagina se a gente
replicar isso tá
e isso tudo nasceu que uma
possibilidades
obrigado